christmas is now less than a week away
Consumer Reports has some
recommendations to round out your
holiday shopping if you're still doing
it the organization reviews products
from technology to home appliances and
cars through independent research and
testing in state-of-the-art laboratories
workers have reviewed and tested more
than eight thousand items ratings are
listed on the Company's website consumer
reports Elliot Wyler is here with some
of 2018 stop rated products good morning
hey Johnny come morning you guys how are
you so Elliot let's start with popular
air fryer uh-huh okay so it doesn't use
oil how what model do you recommend so
it's the new wave 6 quart digital air
fryer and I should say Dale and I were
talking about this every Christmas seems
to have like the new kitchen appliance
right last year was the instant pot this
year it's the new wave air fryer the
idea is you're gonna get similar
consistency and taste fried food right
in a deep fryer this just uses a little
bit of oil it should be a lot healthier
our test results found that it produces
nice food but don't think it's gonna
taste like the deep-fried chicken
Arnold's french fries the mozzarella
sticks
McDonald's deep fryer okay a decent
decent appliance for the countertop but
you're not gonna really fool anybody if
you're gonna want that really deep fried
taste maybe that's a good way to start
losing weight then if you're really
enjoying the food and that next question
about fitness trackers because every
year everyone has a new resolution that
they're gonna lose weight and monitor
their fitness and count how many steps
they take which ones do you like and
these can help we like the Fitbit charge
3 this is the newest one in that Fitbit
series it's about a hundred and thirty
dollars you can see a lot of people use
these this has a very easy to read dis
display easy to sync with your
smartphone it does all of that one thing
to keep in mind these still look like
trackers right so if you're going for a
fashion accessory you don't have a lot
of options here if you're looking for
something like nice looking to wear on
on your wrist but they work very well at
tracking steps mileage heartbeat things
like that can we go to the Apple watch I
just got my first one I love this thing
and I'm not I'm a tech challenged person
huh so I didn't think that I'd be able
to navigate it but I got a bigger screen
but you can track your heart rate you
can track your step you can really track
your sleep exactly so you tested this
how did it do please give it a good
grade the ad that Apple watch this the
series Ford did very well so think about
all the things that we just talked about
with the fitness tracker then you add
apps and connectivity on half is what
you have with your Apple watch we put
that through rigorous tests in water we
drop it we scratch it we test the
battery life
the Apple watch with a cellular
connection did very well about $550 it's
significantly more than the fitness
tracker so if your primary use is just
to track your steps
the Fitbit would be a good option for
much less money but people love the
Apple take a one stop shop
yeah the Health section and you know
what I really do do and you need to have
the iPhone by the way to get the full
functionality of that let's talk about
smart phones because I understand only
one out of 74 models kept its glass
intact when dropped a hundred times in a
tumbling machine which was the one that
passed that's the newest Samsung that is
a yes Sam the newest Samsung now one
thing to keep in mind you are correct
with that that it the screen was was
fine the battery life is also great for
this but the the distance in our top
rated smartphones in other words top to
bottom is about four or five points so
if you're looking at a Samsung if you're
looking at the latest Apple iPhones
these all score very well in Consumer
Reports ratings now if you have one of
the other phones and you drop it in two
breaks and it shatters you'll need to
clean it up with a robo vacuum first
time at the Consumer Reports rodeo so
which ones floors do this so these have
been around for a number of years
Consumer Reports has tested these for a
while and they are getting better the
caveat here is they're not going to
replace your primary vacuum just yet
particularly if you're a neat freak our
top rated Robo vac is a samsung it's a
little over five hundred dollars does
very well on bare floors and carpeting
so these things have gotten a lot better
it's just I think you have to set your
expectations for whole-house deep-clean
can I talk about your testing process
because you guys take it very seriously
starting with you buy all the products
you test consumer reports you say cannot
be bought we cannot be bought every
product that we have talked about today
we have purchased at retail just like
you can we then have engineers and
scientists that put these products use
them and test them the same way you
would at home I always say we are not
Mythbusters we're not trying to break
something we're trying to use it to give
you the knowledge to make a smart choice
in the marketplace you guys do a great
job how much energy we appreciate it I'm
happy to be here yes thanks thanks I
really appreciate it for more Consumer
Reports recommendations this holiday
season visit our website at CBS this
morning calm